[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys we like to keep
careful here very careful and today
we're going to talk about the worst math
problems we ever had to deal with
all right let's go for it
oh geometry is it even considered mass
i'm [ __ ] with geometry over
trigonometry what about physics you
don't even know what trigonometry
exactly i know what geometry is though
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man we're going to talk
about the real stuff okay fine
okay so oh we're gonna get a little bit
closer you ever had a chick have a crush
on you before
let's talk about the real stuff boys
they say men are not in touch with their
emotions yeah but let's break those
barriers and say hey i'm afraid to cry
and i'm not afraid to talk about love
i kind of want to see joe do this for
like 20 more minutes come back to one
man joe here we go i'm just going to
hype the video and then we'll do it in
the last 45 seconds
now now the prompt sounds so
why is that boring
what's the prompt it was the real one so
look
we are gonna start with steve this time
but we're gonna talk about some past
jobs experiences and things that
happened or people that we may have yes
i [ __ ] at work
why do you ask let's go and get into
that one
so here's the thing right give us the
details
so i used to be a janitor
at my previous job at my first job shut
the [ __ ] up really i was it was january
because my dad had a medical wholesale
company and he didn't want to pay a
janitor you know and then he's like hey
you're the janitor and i was like son of
a [ __ ]
and yeah so i was a janitor there and
then i didn't pay you like um like on
the books like just the right way or was
it like here's [ __ ] 20 bucks you're
the janitor like you know what i mean i
think yeah it was like father hiring son
it was by the books yeah they i got like
a check every every two weeks follow-up
question was your sister working the hot
one of course she was that's how that's
how i [ __ ] at work
[Laughter]
so
uh yeah it was it was later at night and
the thing about this particular office
building was it was all glass right so
it's like a fish bowl if it's lit up at
night oh yeah and so my girlfriend at
the time came over to
to my work and it was just me because i
was just cleaning up in the at night
and you know she kind of gave me a
[ __ ] in the hallway and then we kind
of [ __ ] like next to one of the
bathrooms like in one of the little
inlets
she was a trooper that's pretty tight
pretty cool you ever think back and like
you know now i take showers before i
have sex right yeah and i'm just like
dude thank you for all the girls like in
high school and college that just did it
without
any hygiene
it was like
they had bad gag reflexes because
they're like
oh god
how do you think about it your
ex-girlfriend
you were working all day
as a janitor sweating your balls off
literally and she [ __ ] comes over to
suck your dick yeah
that's no matter what they do i feel
like that's that's you just got to give
it up for them like thank you
he gets it up for them that's for sure
[Laughter]
i don't get it i don't get it
all right joe your turn you said you
[ __ ] somebody on the work uh at the
job too right
no no no i actually never [ __ ] that
work yeah
i [ __ ] people from work and i didn't
know how common and easy this stuff was
because everybody in the corporate space
is just horny and [ __ ] they don't
they're not in college anymore they
don't know how to meet people but i
think
if you if you work in a restaurant right
and then there's a bar attached to it i
think
that is like [ __ ] central everyone's
[ __ ] each other yeah
that's the bar where were you sounds so
weird [ __ ] centuries or the coyote ugly
kylie ugly
yeah i was working at a
volcano in pasadena and then it would
get wild on the weekends people would be
[ __ ] awesome yeah
i i had two workplace
uh
uh romance
romance rendezvous
i like that yeah and one
rendezvous by jojitsukawa yeah one was
at the restaurant bar in pasadena
volcano it doesn't exist anymore you
[ __ ] that volcano no i never [ __ ] at
work we're gonna keep on saying i've
never [ __ ] at work okay [ __ ] outside
of work yes but i i [ __ ] my co-workers
but not at work yeah the closest thing
though is um i used to work at this
water company
and um
so like you know like there was the
suits and then the warehouse people
right and then the warehouse people were
in the back and then like
you know like warehouse dudes are always
like just [ __ ] kind of flirting
with girls that come in and out of the
you know like you know the office space
so regular dudes yes regular dudes just
like we don't do the [ __ ] whistle
whistle hole construction worker whoo
wow like we don't do that but like you
know you're bored and you're just
constantly fur flirt
constantly
you're just [ __ ] flirting with
everybody the grandmas the young girls
whatever right everybody anybody can get
it started with grandmas and then added
young girls
a lot of grandma's right right now
young girls a lot of grandma's working i
feel like we're missing the middle demo
there's a lot of range
so one of the one of the uh front desk
like secretary girls like
got her number
and i was like cool right and we're like
flirting around on text and it just gets
like
beyond flirting and then like
things get out of hand where she goes to
the bathroom takes a picture
of a straight croc shot
yeah on the toilet like like a selfie
[ __ ] shot what
he's on opens on with panties on right
wow
a lot of bases wow no she [ __ ] does
one of these right like [ __ ] takes a
picture on the toilet with her panties
on whatever right sends it to me
and then basically tells me tonight and
i'm like okay and then she lives near
the workplace so i stayed and slept over
and and had fun and i was like damn this
[ __ ] really happens in the real world
like the [ __ ] crazy dude
i don't even know no because i was like
i didn't even know this kind of [ __ ]
happens like i was just
you know like pushing my limits and
seeing where this will go i didn't
expect like her to be so fortunate but
it slept at work i didn't [ __ ]
disclose this to hr
no i didn't do it what the [ __ ] man but
also like he's like i gotta hit the
grandma next first she was like a a a
single like mid-30s girl right how old
were you at the time i was like 20 what
when did i graduate college like 23 24
23 maybe yeah working on up
yeah so i was like i don't know like i
don't know where this would go and like
[ __ ] man my mind's still on like oh you
know like yeah maybe we'll flirt and
then we'll go catch dinner and [ __ ] like
i would i didn't think like it was gonna
be like oh yeah and then she goes to the
bathroom and sends me that and i'm like
holy [ __ ] i'll have to take her to
dinner
you know
and then what's crazy and then what
happened the next day he married her
[Laughter]
he's like i quit
i'm out no i remember specifically she
said something like um
don't catch feelings for me because i am
not like
something
along the lines of like i'm not someone
you want to get involved with like that
does that make you want her more nicer
to say that sick
no
dude joe's like okay
most embarrassing thing that the chick
that i i was [ __ ] at my work said to
me in my response this is the most
embarrassing [ __ ] so she goes uh
she goes yeah you don't want to get
involved with me i'm i'm a bit of uh
like a i'm like a hurricane and i'm like
well i'm a storm chaser that's what you
say
but that's what she gets we're saying a
hurricane
she started it it's brutal that's the
lame line that she said absolutely
right-handed god said that may god
strike me dead if i'm lying
it's so embarrassing what did she say i
had to tell you guys so i'm your sister
so yeah she fountained
yeah
i mean dude it was just you were just
that age right that early 20s [ __ ] where
you just like i don't know the
melodrama's nuts they're so romantic
steve yeah right it's pretty good though
i'm a stormtrooper
it's
that kind of vernacular it's like that's
that's so good yeah but then now i'm
like god damn dude i would kill that guy
you
you adapted to the situation
if she said a a tornado i think that
would be more like yeah yeah did you
pick her up and in the comments storm
chasers only changed i couldn't
yeah
fair enough i was going for it didn't
work nice dude thank you thank you thank
you the 20 year old steve stage um more
funny stories from past work experiences
hey bart you have a barbell game you
[ __ ] at work right come on you guys
you guys own a [ __ ] a barbell or cage
you [ __ ] that one you got one of those
ones no way
you got one of those franchises
no we never really [ __ ] you guys
don't get post workout horny as [ __ ] we
do we go go home
we go it's so hot i never desecrated our
office with a girl the office is
desecrated regardless of sex that's
right i thought we've all [ __ ] on the
arcade machine already
huh just kidding
i desecrated it different ways i came on
my ikea table
you had sex at work then
nah but i was by myself there's a bunch
of there's a bunch of ikea tables at the
office which one did you facetiming a
girl and i put the [ __ ] computer i
mean i put it up like this and then i i
was jacking off and i was like i can't
stop and it was a clown
and i was like god damn that's my own
table i should have done it on [ __ ]
the host desk or something
[Laughter]
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as
anxiety stress ow pain
and sleeplessness too talk about
sleeplessness we are actually here in
las vegas right now this is a suite
and uh you know what happens when vegas
calls oh huh you go out late
you like to gamble you get high anxiety
in a positive way because you're winning
or losing money who knows but what
happens all the time is i get so damn
hyped that i cannot go to sleep till
like six in the morning and i'm like i
gotta go and do jk news tomorrow i don't
know what i'm going to do so i said
i have the fields let me put a few drops
under my tongue and start my nighttime
routine
yeah because they don't even have
windows in here so sometimes you're just
going and going and going and going and
going and then you're like holy [ __ ]
it's 4am
we still gotta film our specials out
here in the las vegas so that's what's
so cool about feels if you have any
trouble dealing with sleeplessness
anxiety or stress
feels is premium cbd delivered right to
your door and like joe said it's very
easy to take take a couple drops right
underneath your tongue and if you need
some help they have a hotline that will
walk you through the whole process so
you don't have to go like oh man do i
gotta experiment all by myself no
someone will be there for you and if you
use the special code feels.com
off the record guess what you get 50 off
plus free shipping that's insane that's
f e a l s
dot com slash off the record to get 50
percent off plus free shipping
you can't stop
you could have stopped at least you told
her you can't stop yeah she knew oh my
god
you know
when you guys phone [ __ ] right don't you
try to sync it up so you can come
together and explode
like
do you guys have phone sex like that
like periods i've done that because i do
i'm not gonna lie i do try to pick it up
you know i'm a gentleman i try to i try
to wait
it's usually hard because the way that
god make with men and women is like
girls take way longer to come
and we can come pretty fast
so like it's it's kind of torture
because you want to bust but you also
want to be a gentleman and savor the
moment because it's a special intimate
time yeah but you want to [ __ ] come
together but i always [ __ ] come and
then feel guilty that i didn't save it i
like to be realistic so i'm like i'm
going down i'm like that's a little ripe
tonight maybe we should just go right in
and then you know and then she and then
i'm like okay i'm in oh my oh i came i
gotta go to bed
it happened so quick it's just i gotta
go
i got i gotta go i gotta go oh
nick you never [ __ ] in the middle of a
training thing i've never i've never had
sex at work man i feel like i'm letting
you guys all down you are a lot of good
people down at home too yeah and
everyone's the
when we get back when we get back what
you need to do is go to
bone her in the emergency room
go to the jk office
take the key okay enjoy yourself i'll do
it on joe's desk there it is it's
already came on wait is joe's desk the
one that i said no it's not that was the
one in my office oh yeah you're lucky
you're lucky
i eat off that table i could have told
you it was but i appreciate it oh it was
your back room let's go yeah yeah it was
my own michael switches the tables
around during jk party and stuff so we
really don't know it's a [ __ ] lottery
we never know i'm in my office don't
worry guys
and then oh afterwards i was so tired i
fell out i fell on the sleep floor
you didn't wipe it off first
it's like you don't know the order but i
took a nap on the ground on the girl's
end she sees joe and he's like i can't
control that and then he busts all the
street and she's like um lucky chick
people fall down and passes out i'm so
lucky oh my god
i don't know what's gonna be about that
hey it's kind of [ __ ] at the
workplace though isn't it yeah it is
it's still a type of sex it is
maybe that's true uh levels i don't
think i've ever had face time sex before
it's modern right it's it's digital
modern yeah it's the new age it's the
news it's metaverse section
sex yeah i mean facetime was a really
really wonderful invention for servicing
that particular niche name yeah that
market yeah
do you guys remember um cyber sex where
you know yeah
on aim we are [ __ ] we are [ __ ]
yeah
i'm close i'm close i'm close i [ __ ]
love doing cyber sex right like you
could go into chat rooms and then you
could be like hey wanna cyber asl right
that crazy that's like an extinct idea
isn't it i could have been dude they
didn't know they were [ __ ] with a 13
year old boy you know what i mean like
i probably couldn't spell and [ __ ] the
best thing has been a 15 year old girl
before
15 year old characters and role playing
the 15 year old
i'm fingering myself
all like dainty and stuff do that we
should always catfish and prank the
[ __ ] cambodian chat room
why the cambodian chatter i don't know
we just liked it
when i was cyber i wouldn't lie about my
age or sex but i'd be like i'm from
texas and then at the end of it after
i'm done with them i'm like i'm from
california
[ __ ]
idiot
i was still like honorable though
because i was like oh i don't want them
to
i don't want them to think that i'm
lying and like i'll get caught so i
wouldn't be like oh i'm 18 i'll be like
i'm 17 because i'm 13 and maybe they'll
believe me because like buying
cigarettes right you don't you don't try
to be like i'm 25 you're like no i just
turned 18. so like when i cyber sex i
was like i'm 17.
but that's still stupid as [ __ ]
because it's still an underage person
yeah but i remember watching this one um
fox news thing at night fox news to like
next
news at 11 your child might already lost
their virginity
online and i was like [ __ ] that's me oh
my god if my mom ever finds out i lost
my virginity like i'm an online hoe like
[ __ ] meanwhile you got a rubber band
around your dick
at the saran wrap
and five kids
and i felt so guilty because i was like
you know grew up held a good christian
boy [ __ ] and i'm like wait man i thought
virginity meant like having real sex but
i was like [ __ ] how am i gonna deal with
this and i and i was like should i tell
people at church i don't know what i'm
gonna do oh you were that concerned
about that i didn't know i thought
because i was lost virginia online yeah
uploaded your hymen to the [ __ ] cloud
have it to the cloud yes to tell his
first check he's like okay so i busted
online a couple times yeah i'm sorry
she's like you're a virgin he's like nah
nah i lost it online all over my
keyboard all over my tv she was pissed
dude because they were saving each other
you know i was saving myself for
marriage and i didn't know that i was
like violating myself yeah
dude your body count must be crazy
online body coming yeah it's crazy all
my body counts sexual escapades started
at 12 years old what's higher you're 90
000.
what's higher is your body count online
or your body count in person online
because if i started at like 12 13 and i
was addicted bro like every day i was
like oh i can't wait to cyber sex i was
getting horny as [ __ ] i'm like i'm
kissing your lips i'm kissing your
nipples what color are your nipples oh
and i'll be sitting there with a heart
on the whole time oh i'm a chat with
this other person what kind of hair do
you have joe has so many aol kids out
there that's
crazy good thing this is pre-nsa like
all that stuff's probably just gone yeah
it's gone imagine no record of it i jail
baited myself
i reverse true i reverse molested
like there could have been a full-grown
adult there
like playing a fantasy right which
they're probably not knowing that
they're cyber sexy with a child which i
probably did right they hoped yeah what
was your screen name
uh 15 year old boy
[Laughter]
azn apex one two three or something [ __ ]
like for example wow apex jesus
yeah i had a couple of different ones
mine was [ __ ] azn
that's good [ __ ] asian fuckasian
just so you know what you're getting
right yeah okay good oh my god yeah
yeah but i was really good at seducing
people though but one time how would you
do it what was the move i uh i would
just be like you know you go into the
chat baby
and then you you ask cyber asl
yeah and today i'll be like you know oh
um
i'll be like [ __ ]
asian
six feet 17 years old whatever right
like looking for a girl whatever right
and then like they'll start dming i mean
like i aiming and then you start like oh
where you from and then you'll be like
yeah what are you wearing and then like
you i'm gonna take off your panties and
[ __ ] and whatever right
[ __ ] 12 year old sex ever shits dude
right and there were this is free emotes
too i felt so
[ __ ]
backstabbed because a dude
got me so off thinking that there was a
hot ass girl
yeah they even emailed me a [ __ ]
picture of the surfer girl my favorite
right that's that's a hot take right
there man i was i had i was i got really
good at typing with one hand too and
jacking off with my left because i was
better with my right so i was like
right and i'm like oh and then he goes
dude i can't believe people do this [ __ ]
and i'm like what do you mean i thought
you like it and i'm a guy dude and i'm
like oh
man
could i at least stay the character yeah
[ __ ] ruin it man
bear the lead yo his green name white
apex wants you
why did that dan i was like dude he goes
yeah i never cybered before and i was
like really it's really dope like he's
still talking to him how come friends i
was embarrassed but at the same time i'm
all like
you were in a cyber chat yeah like did
you guys team up afterwards and show
them the ropes no i was just like oh man
like i thought you were a real girl
why'd you do that and then he's like
you're a loser i can't believe people do
you [ __ ] watch who was [ __ ] sad
you're a loser you know i did do a thing
where i would go to a like a cyber sex
chat room and i would have this
pre-written thing
and uh and i'd be like hi how are you
like 14 female california and they're
like oh yeah that's [ __ ]
i'm like okay cool and then i would send
this like paragraph that i've
pre-written is like i'm fred phelps i'm
with the federal bureau of me
chris
yeah dude
you would just see like their name has
left the room like
dude i would do that with my friends we
would [ __ ] laugh
so we couldn't breathe so mean
i was more offended that
that fool baited switched me yeah and i
just i wanted to come so you didn't say
like
joke's on you i'm a child that's also a
good i didn't even know it was a thing i
i was like you know i was like oh okay
cool i'm back on i just wanted like i
was like man you're a guy like why would
you play a trick on me i was like that's
[ __ ] up i didn't lie to you well i
lied about my age your height
i think he fully has online sex with you
and he calls you a loser
after you came after you guys both came
yeah he was like
he sucked your dick so hard yeah i got
you losers you busted in his box he's
like you're a loser he's like i gotta
clean up dude bye loser [ __ ] use and
abuse me and then make fun of me dude
like [ __ ] you
i just and then i'll like did that stop
me no i was like i'm just gonna find
another side excuse me and abuse me i'm
gonna go to another cyber partner dude
joe's a sexual maverick dude 100
stop me no
you